it's lovely to see you your character in
your next is quite and ingenious one is
that she comes up with some inventive
ways of trying to keep everyone safe in
the film so I want to know how inventive
do you think you are in real life
and how would you cope in her situation
how inventive am i I feel like I'm
pretty inventive person I'm someone that
gets bored really quickly so I'm always
looking for new ways to excite myself
just in day-to-day life so you know
hopefully I'm inventive but not in the
same exact ways that that Aaron is and
yeah and no I when it comes to the art
of killing people I'm not sure hopefully
I can't even comment on that which I
can't so that's thank goodness we
escaped that one you pretty click after
real life in terms of you know
feistiness and that sort of stuff cuz
she is isn't she in the film yeah yeah I
think it was a nice there was a there
was a way that I wanted to really find
that she was normal so people could
relate to her straight up she's not your
you know superhero with special powers
or anything like that I just wanted to
establish the fact that she's a really
normal girl from a normal ish
background and is really seeking
normality you know in coming into this
family reunion and meeting your
boyfriend's parents for the first time
you just want to impress them and so I
think everybody's kind of familiar with
that situation we've all been there
before so uh it was nice to find that
just realness in her before you kind of
have to bring out the parts that aren't
necessarily embodied in everybody and
and through her you know survivalist
compound training up upbringing which I
thought was pretty cool you know that's
that's how she's she's tough she's it's
just a natural toughness that she's not
even aware I don't think that she even
has until she has to pull and call upon
these skills I mean it's a pretty
horrific first meeting with your
potential the worst can it really yeah
I'm assuming you haven't heard anything
coiours but no I mean thank goodness you
know we've all had experiences I'm sure
in in meeting the parents and um you
know feeling that pressure to kind of
impress but yeah thank goodness I can't
say that it's gone as bad as this one
and you could kind of person who if you
heard a strange noise you know in a room
in the house or even whether you're
alone with other people would you
investigate it with you hightail out no
I I get up immediately because I just
curiosity killed the cat
you know so I have to know what what was
that like and I'm up immediately and I
need to figure out where that noise came
from and and yeah if something's going
on I need to know about it like for sure
so I would definitely be up
investigating possibly after shooting
this movie with a knife in my hand yeah
we'll see same thing you fix up some
skills now for this for future
investigation yeah well hopefully just
for investigations just that word is
will cover it but um yeah the skills
that I picked up in this movie hopefully
I never have to use them but it's it's
kind of like that thing of I always
wished I'd grown up learning
self-defense and I think that every
woman really really should have grown up
with a little bit of self-defense
knowledge be it through martial arts
karate you know whatever it is that
makes you feel a little bit more safe is
really important so I I definitely
learned a couple of skills where even
from shooting the movie I do feel a
little more secure you know we're
talking about that sort of actions I'm
that kick-ass nurse as it were or
toughness and you've talked in the past
about how you'd like to maybe remake the
Lara Croft movie is Tomb Raider what is
it that appeals to you about that
character cuz she is very kind of tough
and go isn't she a bit in a way like
well like Aaron in your necks and why
would you like to see that going if you
could do that
yeah I it's it's those exact types of
roles that I'm really seeking roles that
I can sink my teeth into as an actor but
also as somebody that came through so
many sports and is really super super
physical the more you can you can put me
in training and the more that I get to
actually do on a set the better for me
you know standing and delivering a line
every now and then gets quite old quite
quickly for me and so when it comes to
physical roles i I just thrive on that
and something like the Lara Croft series
would just be amazing because it's it's
the same type of female empowerment that
we're trying to get across and I think
it's just such a stand-up role model for
all women out there and you know if I
could be the one that can can can
portray that and and hopefully kick
start that off again in this generation
that would be amazing because it's been
a it's been a little while I feel that
we've had that sort of female role model
to sort of look up to and that's what
really attracted me to this script it
was every way that the character was
written I wanted the opportunity to be
the one to portray that and finally you
mentioned that it's of course Aaron is a
real live crowd and she's grounded in
that said she's not superheroes she said
now they've got me thinking just we
didn't recently said that there aren't
enough super heroines on the right
screen yeah I mean if somebody like him
came along if you could be involved in
and Avengers 3 that comes along or one
of those big superhero movies would you
do you put your hand up and say yes I'm
in and who would you like to play yeah
give me a lecture or something you know
like something really really cool like
where the because I have so much fun
coming on to set sky night dress ups and
that's what I loved about this movie was
sitting in a makeup chair and walking
out as the least attractive you could
possibly look you know it's blood all
over you and just like it has mattered
and you know it you never once cared
what you look like it's all about the
performance and just really giving that
the realism that it deserves and so when
it comes to like those types of
superhero movies it would be really fun
to come in and put on like the lycra
tight red cat suit and you know that
would come back a lot to the dance
experience that I have as well I feel
and you know utilizing kicks and martial
arts and spins and you know I Acrobat so
I you throw in a couple of flips and
it's just I I know it would be really
fun so somebody give me the chance to do
it
thank you so much